The supply chain, freight,
transportation, logistics,
it's a trillion dollars a year.
This is hundreds of thousands,
millions of loads of freight
that are moving throughout
the United States every year.
In terms of source of emissions
of greenhouse gases,
it’s a massive producer.
[In The Green: The Business
of Climate Action]
[Presented by: TED Countdown
The Climate Pledge]
[Oren Zaslansky
Company: Flock Freight]
[Sector: Logistics, Location: USA]
The global supply chain is roughly
broken up into what we call modes.
By far the largest mode
is what we call full truckload.
That is around a 400
billion-dollar-a-year mode in the US
and in theory is the most efficient
way to move freight.
But about half of the big trucks
you see on the highway,
they're only running half full.
If half of those trucks are only half full
we burn the same amount of fuel,
the same amount of diesel,
create the same amount
of greenhouse gas to run a truck half full
as we do completely full.
We're addressing that.
We are getting those trucks full.
We do algorithmic carpooling
of truckload freight.
We've created a software solution
where you can ride-share your freight.
They give us a little bit of data,
and they say, "I'm here today,
there tomorrow."
"I'm empty."
"I'm a quarter empty."
We take that data and we create
a more optimal outcome for that driver
and for that carrier,
which is just simply
those two basic things:
the shortest distance between two points
and making sure the truck is full,
which also creates an income earning
opportunity for the driver.
The driver has been paid to haul
a load that's only half full.
We can create a world
in which they can have dynamic,
fluid access to freight and revenue.
The ability to kind of say,
"I want to opt in or opt out."
If I want to work a little more,
I can make a little bit more.
As we scale, we will fundamentally
bring down the paradigm of modes
and create even greater efficiency.
The problem with these various modes,
they are not integrated with one another.
They don't share data,
they don't share visibility.
If we could find a way to share this data,
then we could create
an entirely new supply chain
that is much, much less resource-intensive
from a capital standpoint,
from an infrastructure standpoint
but also from a carbon standpoint.
You would have a world in which
there were no longer any modes
and everything would be
placed into the river
and just flows where it needs to go.
This is a massive opportunity
for whether it's greenhouse gas
and sustainability
or value and cost for the US supply chain.
Through more data,
we have better insights,
we make better decisions,
we build more valuable products.
Change does not typically occur quickly.
So I guess my advice to people
on the planet Earth is dream bigger,
have higher expectations.
The next wave of innovators
are going to be focused
on neutralizing carbon.
In doing so, they'll be the beneficiaries
of very valuable businesses
that are also doing their part
to save the world.